it's a new year drew everyone are you
feeling it new year new energy
are you ready to get healthy uh-huh a
lot of people i think in the new year
want to do like big things and be like
i'm going to run 40 miles a day yeah
and i think bright january is being put
to the test it is
but you know okay so there's um people
think you should start small
and do little things rather than big
grand gestures and the new york times
they say they have just the plan for us
they say we should think
small think of fitness like we think of
food and start
exercise snacking that's what they call
it which i think is cruel because it
makes me want to cookie
snacking but what they mean is little
bursts of exercise when you can fit it
in
so could you would you bear with me and
try something of course
while we finish the story can we do
squats right up front yeah okay
come here ready so
i'm not kidding this is the pair of
pants that i had to put a bra strap into
because i started the show and they fit
and then i stressed eight and then they
didn't but i'm working my way back
you look great you look great but we can
always be a work in progress so i'm
gonna do a squat and see if i can hold
it as we do this story okay
three two go and this is where we go up
okay
science scientists say uh even little
bite size
four second bursts of activity can have
a huge impact on your health
so instead of reaching for a salty chip
um you can just you know do a wall
sit what's a wall set oh it's like when
you go back
and you do oh let's do those now okay
ow i'm not doing that i'm going back my
glutes are on fire which is great
they say when you're on like a phone
call or zoom you can hold like a yoga
pose
oh yeah like a tree pose okay or you can
just
oh oh i could do it right for a second
for one second i could do it
um or how about this trend trampolines
are huge
goldie hawn she's obsessed with the
trampoline and they say look at her
that's what she's doing
okay now that is a woman after my own
heart that looks like a clip from our
show
right no she can totally die here and
nasa
nasa says that trampolines burn more
calories than jogging
yeah but does anyone out there have
a trampoline so i got one for my kids
um during the pandemic because i was
like you know i'm sorry you can't do
anything see a friend you know
yeah go to school but here's a small
trampoline
you can bounce your way to happiness
here's what ended up happening
every day they asked me to jump on the
trampoline with them and bounce them
and i'm so old and rickety at this point
i'm so afraid i've slipped a disc
you know listen i'm 45 i carried two
children there's a lot of relaxant that
goes on in the body
and it's like i'm so worried to damage
myself
so to any parents out there who have to
find excuses
not to get on that trampoline yeah i
wish i was goldie han
can we get can we get one here please i
want to jump up and down
i'll i'll get i'll get you a trampoline
tune in next
week everyone
[Laughter]
okay speaking of fun romps
yes oh yeah i said it
richard okay i saw you instagramming
about this show all week and i was like
should i be watching this
okay so i asked you and you said you're
how many minutes ago i started six
minutes and then i don't know if you saw
the news some stuff started so i was
watching that
yes but now i don't want to watch that
anymore so i might watch this it's funny
you say that because i do think
in the timing is everything as i spoke
about earlier in the show with haley
steinfeld is
the timing of the show couldn't be
better yeah it's if you
want a break um this is where to turn
into and
everybody is it's breaking records on
netflix
it is not something ironically sammy
sullivan um one of our news producers
uh watched it with her parents i'm like
how did you watch this with your parents
eventually i had think they had to leave
like one had to leave the room but it's
so hot
it's so steamy and it's like i think it
might have single-handedly got
me back on a dating app i was like you
know i'm not i am alive
yeah you still got it wow bridgerton
okay because it is so hard to get me to
binge watch a show there's so much on
it's like it's
it's easier to get a mortgage i need
like letters of recommendation and
everything
so does it have like it has beautiful
people yes
and it has um is there a lot of hubba
hubba going on oh my gosh
so much it's like it's cinemax it's on
netflix but it's
it's like corset cinemax and i was
worried when it ended that it was going
to be over
and it turns out i found out from our
news division we did some recon there
are eight books in the series so
if you like it when it ends and you want
more i think it's coming which is good
so here's what i'm going to do drew
because you maybe watch the queen's
gambit and i loved it
so now i'm going to trust you i'm going
to spend my weekend watching bridgerton
instead of the news
and i'll report back uh or both you know
one is a civic duty and one is a nice
antidote to it and i just want to say
one thing about bridgerton that
might be my favorite thing about it is
uh
one day i heard oprah winfrey say
that when she was doing the film a
wrinkle in time
she looked around and she saw mindy
kaling and reese witherspoon and herself
and she said i believe this is what a
film should look like
and when i watch bridger 10 i keep
hearing that quote of hers over and over
in my head
and to netflix and shonda rhimes i thank
them
so much for so seamlessly giving us what
a show should look like